get treated hopefully they get
discharged if they don't get discharged
they stay in the hospital they decline
they become intubated if they become
intubated the longer you're on a
ventilator the less likely you will be
to get off that ventilator so that's the
trajectory we see right and the
intubations most people who are into
baited will not come off the ventilator
so that's a troubling number the
intubation number which is real but the
three-day intubation rate again is a
dance down relative to where we were so
all the numbers are basically saying the
same thing number of discharges goes up
because we had that high hospitalization
rate people stay for a week two weeks
they get discharged that's why the
discharges are a function of the
hospitalization rate three-day average
of the discharges you see again
basically flat so it's all reinforcing
the same thing a flattening of all these
numbers you're not seeing a great
decline in the numbers but you're seeing
a flattening and you're also seeing a
recurrence of the terrible news which is
the number of lives lost which is 758
somebody asked the question once can you
ever get numb to these seeing these
numbers unfortunately no 758 people lost
their lives in a 24-hour period I speak
to many families who are going through
this many people who lost loved ones
everyone is a face and a name and a
family that is suffering on this weekend
which were many people in this state and
in this nation is a high religious
holiday which is already distorted
because we have churches closed
we have temples closed so this is truly
tragic news and I want every family to
know that there are no thoughts and
prayers and we're sorry that they had to
go through this and I want them to know
that New Yorkers did everything humanly
possible to be there for their loved
ones and try to save those lives and
we're proud of that
you see also a flattening and the number
of lives lost at a terribly high rate
but if you look back over the past
several days you see there's a certain
continuity to that number again that's
the one number that I look forward to
seeing drop as soon as I open my eyes in
the morning and it has been flattening
but flattening at a terribly high level
again to put it in context nine thousand
three hundred eighty five lives lost
when you add those from yesterday put in
the context of 9/11 which was supposed
to be the tragedy of my lifetime twenty
seven hundred and fifty three lives lost
we're now at nine thousand three hundred
and eighty-five big question for
everyone is when do we reopen people
want to get on with their lives people
want to get out of the house cabin fever
we need the economy working people need
a paycheck life has to function when do
we reopen when do we reopen look the
answer is we want to reopen as soon as
possible
everyone does on a societal level
everyone does on a personal level let's
just end this nightmare right Groundhog
Day you get up every day it's the same
routine you almost lose track of what
day of the week it is because they don't
even have meaning anymore and there's
all sorts of anxiety and stress that
we're all dealing with so we want to
reopen as soon as possible
the caveat is we need to be smart in the
way we reopen
what a smart mean means a coordinated
approach a regional approach and a safe
approach nobody wants to pick between a
public health strategy and an economic
strategy and as governor of the state
I'm not going to pick one over the other
we need a public health strategy that is
safe that is consistent with an economic
strategy how do you reopen but how do
you do it in a way that is smart from a
public health point of view the last
thing we want to see is an uptick in
that infection rate and then up taking
those numbers that we work so hard to
bring down so we need a strategy that
coordinates business and schools and
transportation and workforce what New
York pause did is it stopped everything
at the same time it was a blunt device
but it shut down everything at the same
time we're going to need testing more
testing faster testing then we now have
when you start to move people back to
work and we're gonna need federal help
there is no doubt about that
I did a joint statement with governor
Hogan who is the chairman of the
National Governors Association
he is a Republican I am the vice chair
I'm a Democrat those of you who don't
know and we did a joint statement that
said look the federal government did a
stimulus bill a bill that was supposed
to help move the economy alone called
the federal cares Act the federal cares
act just almost ignored state
governments when you ignore a state
government you ignore our situation we
have a 10 to 15 billion dollar deficit
we got a budget done but our budget was
basically contingent on what happens
going forward and without federal
assistance how does this state economy
come back how do we really start to fund
schools it's
and that's going to happen that has to
happen from a federal level there is no
level above a state government that can
make a difference besides the federal
government we did a statement on a
bipartisan basis that said the federal
government has to fix this in the next
bill and we called 500 billion dollars
for funding for state governments and
again we did that on a bipartisan basis
from New York's point of view the past
bills were like most federal passed
bills they were went through the
political process and to get a bill
passed in Washington everyone has to get
their piece of the pie to pass a bill I
understand politics I understand it very
well that's not how they should be
operating here and you did an injustice
to the places that actually had the need
which from an American taxpayer point of
view that's what you were trying to
correct you were trying to correct the
devastation of the virus so we're then
correct the devastation of the virus not
everything has to be an opportunity for
pork-barrel right you look at where the
money actually went theoretically the
bill distributed funding to States for
corrective action and expenses on
handling the virus Kaiser health which
is a very notable organization said that
Nebraska Montana for example Minnesota
or getting approximately three hundred
thousand dollars per Kovan 19 case New
York State gets approximately twelve
thousand dollars how can that be it can
be because in the Senate it became a
game of political pork and I want my
share as opposed to where is the need
genuinely and New York is vital to this
American economy it's not just about New
York
our economy is vital to this country you
want New York's economy up and running
not just for the good of New York but
for the good of the nation so that was
the purpose of the legislation it missed
the mark I hope they do it next time
a simple easy way to help New York is
right the wrong that the federal
government did when it passed the soft
tax state local tax deductibility that
was just a political maneuver in the
first place
you're trying to help places that are
suffering from the virus repeal the salt
tax which should have never been done as
I said in the first place we're going to
work with our neighboring states because
this is the tri-state area it's a
regional economy I'm going to speaking
with governor Murphy and government
governor Lamont later today on coming up
with every opening plan that is a public
health plan safeguards public health but
also starts to move us towards economic
activation we'll also do an executive
order today which directs employers to
provide essential workers with a cloth
or surgical facemask to their employees
when they are interacting with the
public and they should provide those
masks cost-free
New Jersey did a similar order and I
think governor Murphy was right and I
want to do that here in the state of New
York we have to also expand testing one
of the ways we want to do that is by
executive order we're going to expand
the number of people who are eligible to
do the antibody test we have state
regulations that say who can actually do
the antibody test there are two tests
one is the diagnostic test one is the
antibody test the antibody test tells
you if the person had the virus and got
over the virus that would be a prime
person who
go back to work because they
theoretically have an immunity to the
virus for a period of time they're not
sure what the period of time is there
aren't a tremendously large number of
people with the antibodies which is good
news because we kept down the infection
rate but that is an important test and
we have to get that tested scale and
this executive order will help do that
Happy Easter for all those who are
celebrating happy spring for those who
aren't celebrating spring is my favorite
season what spring says to all of us is
it's a time of rebirth that no matter
how cold the winter no matter how barren
the landscape got the earth comes back
to life and it was flat and it was
barren and it was closed down and then
it comes back to life and for me this
spring especially we have been closed
down we have locked the doors we've
isolated we've hunkered down we've
closed down and away we've never closed
down before we want to talk about a cold
winter where the earth becomes barren
this has been a cold period from a
societal point of view and we've closed
down in a way we've never closed down
but we will come back to life and we
will have a rebirth and that's what
spring is all about and the rebirth is
primarily about our people and about our
spirit the spirit lives they have been a
couple of moments through this that will
stay with me for all time and a couple
of moments that were really dark periods
looking at that number of deaths is a
dark period
the phone calls with families are dark
periods the fear of the
worst-case-scenario of those numbers
going through the roof and overwhelming
the hospital capacity was a dark period
fears of seeing what happened in Italy
and how their healthcare system got
overwhelmed and it could happen here
that was dark number of conversations
that with people who lost their father
their spouse their brother their sister
out of the blue but there's also been
some moments that just were so
inspirational to me that just showed
such a positive spirit you know it's
when things are at their worst is when
you will see the good the bad and the
ugly right when people are under
pressure you see like their true essence
will come out and some people will break
your heart people who you expected to
react differently will just break your
heart and disappoint you but then other
people who you expected nothing from
will show you a strength and a
resilience that just is an inspiration
we were going through a period where we
were afraid of the hospital capacity
peaking and we needed equipment we were
focused on ventilators because
ventilators for this disease it's a
respiratory disease you need ventilators
nobody ever anticipated this kind of
situation so we're in a mad rush for
ventilators and we're shifting
ventilators all over the state and I'm
asking hospitals to cooperate with each
other and lend each other equipment
including ventilators and some hospitals
were great in some hospitals were less
great which you expect but then out of
the blue a phone call came where a
nursing
in upstate New York said we understand
downstate may need ventilators we want
to let them borrow 35 ventilators
unsolicited they just called and offered
the 35 ventilators and we went we picked
up the ventilators and we brought them
downstate but I remember they came in
and they told me a nursing home in
upstate a nursing home is one of the
most vulnerable places in this entire
situation right elderly populations and
in a confined area of a nursing home and
here a nursing home comes forward and
says we want to lend you 35 ventilators
to bring down state I tell you for me
when I heard that news with all this bad
with all this negative something inside
me said you know what we're gonna be
okay we're gonna find our way through
this because there is an inherent
goodness in people that will surprise
you and they will rise to the occasion
and at the end of the day good will win
against bed I believe that and and love
will conquer all so I went
we brought the 35 ventilators back to
pathways which is a nursing and
rehabilitation center I went by there
this morning when they were returning
the 35 ventilators just to say thank you
thank you on behalf of all the people of
the state thank you for their generosity
thank you on behalf of downstate New
York we're in a position now where we're
not going to need the ventilators we're
going to be ok equipment wise unless
things change dramatically but thank you
on behalf of the people of the state as
governor of the state of New York and
thank you for myself because the people
from path
who are watching this broadcast I
couldn't go inside so I didn't really
get a chance to talk to them but I
wanted to say thank you for me from me
because they brought me inspiration and
hope and energy at a time when I
personally really needed it and that
call and that generosity and that love
buoyed my spirit and my feelings and was
such a lift for me and I remember I went
and I talked to the team I said can you
believe how beautiful a gesture this is
so I wanted to say thank you as governor
and for me myself and I Andrew Cuomo
thank you to the people of pathways
questions are there any updates on new
york city schools have you had any
discussions with mayor de Blasio about
path forward on that issue yeah we are
where we are we are where we were the
school's first we have to have a
coordinated approach on the reactivation
if you will schools businesses workforce
transportation it all has to be
coordinated number two it all has to be
coordinated regionally we closed
everything down in a coordinated fashion
and we did it regionally we did it with
New York New Jersey Connecticut that
tri-state area that partnership is very
important for our individual states and
our collective States and we did it with
an Esso Suffolk Westchester the whole
downstate region together in the
tri-state with the tri-state partners
and that's how we will go forward
together so we'll have a coordinated
plan we'll have a regional plan
hopefully we can get on the same
Paige with New Jersey and Connecticut
we're going to try that is the optimum
situation I don't know if we can achieve
it states are a little different
demographically a little different
places but the optimum that we're still
trying is a wholly coordinated approach
part of that process not only will I be
working with governor Murphy and
governor Lamont New Jersey Connecticut
respectively I'll also work with Suffolk
County and Nassau County in Westchester
County in New York City but we will do
it in a coordinated regional approach
just just to extrapolate from that are
you suggesting that New York City
schools could reopen this year all the
schools are closed all the schools in
the downstate and upstate area are
closed they will remain closed we're not
going to open any school until it is
safe from a public health point of view
we won't open schools one minute sooner
than they should be opened but we won't
open schools one late minute later than
they should be opened either
and that has to work in a coordinated
plan with businesses am i as I sit here
prepared to say what we'll be doing in
June no I do not know what we will be
doing in June nobody knows what we will
be doing in June as I said I talked to
the best experts around the globe on
this and the smartest ones all start by
saying I don't know we have to watch and
see and follow the signs follow the data
and see what happens so I'm not prepared
to say what we will do in June we
whatever plan we come up with will be
driven by data and science it will be
coordinated to do all those functions at
once because you can't do one without
the others if you say the schools are
closed through June you're effectively
saying businesses are
closed through June because you can't
put the restart the economy fully
without restarting schools schools are
also provide not just education but
there are also in many ways childcare
for people can then go to work so
coordinate all of that do it regionally
and June is a long way from now we go
day to day to watch those numbers and
we'll work with Jersey in Connecticut
and our local governments in each state
to come up with a coordinated plan I
wouldn't assume anything because Karen
if you say schools aren't going to open
you're saying businesses aren't going to
open now do you is anyone prepared to
sit here today and say businesses are
not going to open through June
you know that's June is a long way away
I've said from day one all these
predictions were going to open
businesses in May we're gonna do this in
May or this in June I think that's all
premature I don't think anybody can make
an informed decision right now and look
every informed projection by experts by
the way has not turned out correct which
is good news right our policies and the
social compliance actually changed or
the projection models and those were
only three four weeks ago so you know
June is a long long way away it seems
like there is a lot of confusion between
the conflicting messages from the mayor
and yourself over schools could close
how do you plan on avoiding that type of
public confusion when it comes to
reopening the state look we have
remained remarkably consistent I work
than glove with the federal government
which has not always been the easiest
relationship right and I work very very
hard to make sure that relationship
works that is a prime relationship for
our state's response I work with local
governments all across the state
sometimes it's less coordinated than we
would like but you know that that
happens when you're dealing with a lot
of local governments but we have to work
with New Jersey Connecticut optimum we
come up with one plan for all three
states that would be great if we can't
come up with the exact same plan similar
plans because we have a tri-state
workforce right you have people who live
in Westchester who work in Connecticut
you're people who live in Connecticut
who worked in New York City you're
people who live in New York City who
worked in New Jersey
this all works as one or it doesn't work
transportation works with economic
development works with housing works
with schools or it doesn't work you
can't have one year spinning if the
other gears aren't spinning that doesn't
work you can't have New York City work
without Nassau Suffolk Westchester
Jersey and Connecticut about a third of
the workforce in New York City comes
from outside of New York City or leaves
New York City to go work in that area so
it's got to work for the whole region or
it doesn't work but how will you respond
to localities that might say you know
we're gonna shut down we're gonna to be
continue to shut down maybe after the
state would like it would like them to
be shut down
how would you respond to a locality who
does that how are you planning to manage
that relationship well look it is I work
cooperatively with all the local
governments and I hope Nassau Suffolk
New York City Westchester New Jersey
Connecticut that we can all get on the
same page that's the ideal
but at the end of the day there's one
page right there's one page in this one
plan hopefully Suffolk agrees Nassau
agrees with sister agrees New York City
agrees you know but you do the best you
can to come up with mutual agreement but
at the end of the day you have one plan
and that's the plane you have to go with
when you say there's one plan one page
are you talking about your own plan
there no why don't we do this again for
you I know it's Sunday New Jersey
Connecticut New York that's the trick to
come up with one page how do you get
three states to agree on one plan and
it's hard
coordination is you know coordination is
great but it's difficult and it requires
compromise but it's also the right way
to do it look for each of the three
states it's easiest for each state to
say you know what I'm going to do my own
thing I'm Connecticut I'm governor
Lamont I'm gonna do a Connecticut plan
why do I have to coordinate with New
Jersey in New York for me it's easier to
say I'm gonna do one plan I'm gonna do
in New York state plan why do I have to
coordinate with governor Murphy and
governor Lamont they want this they want
this we'd have to compromise that after
worked it out yeah it's easier to do it
alone except it's better to do it
together
and in this situation we need to do the
best product that we can do for the
people and that's where I start the best
product is to come up with a plan that
New Jersey Connecticut and New York can
all execute simultaneously which is what
we've done to date right
we made very difficult decisions
together and we implemented them
together because we were very weight
aware of the interplay between these
pieces and
our regional workforce you take an
action in New Jersey that's inconsistent
with what I'm doing in New York you put
people in a very difficult position
because they live in Jersey they work in
New York
or they live in New York and they work
in Jersey you know coordinate if I'm out
there I say coordinate governor Murphy
Governor Cuomo governor Lamont I know
it's a pain in the neck but that's what
I pay you for
so ideally we all get on the same page
because people drive in theaters that is
a good question why it hasn't been
raised yet to ESD to my knowledge I'm
going to advance your argument why where
is the public safety issue use a
drive-in theater you're in the car with
the same people if you make it
non-essential the employees that have to
show up to operate the theater and the
question is you're then making those
employees essential workers because they
would be accepted right they themselves
would then have to interact to operate
so that's what it is for most of the
businesses it's the employees then have
to show up they would have to perform
the service they essentially are putting
themselves at risk as part of it and
that's that's the discussion that we
have each time there is an exception
[Music]
wants to be considered I'm gonna argue
your argument I'm gonna argue against
Rob but I'm gonna argue Empire State
Development is making these decisions
and they're all tricky decisions by the
way you're trying to balance the need
here right but I see your point
I'm going to talk to us deeper character
working relationship with Bill DeBlasio
right now look I understand the mayor's
position he represents in New York City
and the position of I think schools
should be closed that's not an
unreasonable position he doesn't have to
worry about Nassau Suffolk he doesn't
have to worry about New Jersey doesn't
have to worry about Connecticut but I do
I've worked with the homeless since I
was in my 20s you're right fine for the
homeless is not going to be effective
you can't force a homeless person into a
shelter
unless there's certain endangering their
own lives or endangering others but
leaving that aside the shelters do have
to operate under those guidelines
however and whatever facility is
operating by the local government has to
adhere to those guidelines of the
testing swaps I have not heard that you
haven't received that but we'll check
after today and see if they've gotten in
touch with us
they going to be issuing yes speak to
that moose yes so what we're saying is
you're an essential worker you should be
protected you shouldn't have to go out
and put yourself in unnecessary danger
and continue the spread of the virus and
so we're putting it on the employers so
if you're a state employee and you're
essential servant who is interacting
with the public in some capacity yes
it's on the state to provide that mask
hydro treatments with Sarah except that
has I turn any additional yeah with we
have done there was probably about 2,000
patients who are being treated with
hydrochloric and I don't know if it's
with is it through max well not through
hospitals I believe there's actually a
federal trial on it but we were supplied
the drug we left it to the hospitals and
the doctors because they have to do the
administration of it but I don't think
there's any results yet to speak of it's
been about I'd say a week ten days
something like that that patients have
been getting it I don't know what the
period is where it would kick in but I
assume that we'll be getting data soon
and look on the hydro chloric two things
I liked the president hope it works I
don't know if it works I'm not a doctor
but everybody hopes something works
right I think would be unnatural not to
hope that it works we're a hundred
percent pushing every kind of drug
therapy every company every research
Brookhaven lab is open seven days a week
24 hours a day with all sorts of
research going on we're praying for
something to work I don't have the data
yet though
federal the federal pretty sorry excuse
me one second about April 20th we think
we're going to have results with some
anecdotal evidence though yes it's
anecdotal so it's when I'm speaking to a
hospital administrator I'll ask them or
I'll have a group on the phone I'll ask
them and they have said they've seen
some positive results I don't know what
that means Jesse from a trial point of
view but people have said to me they've
had positive results I think we're going
to get actual reports on April 20
[Music]
specific has who has not been told by
the supplied task force that they're
coming off the CDC crisis guidelines so
as you be as all of you have reported at
various points there's been something of
a disconnect between the hospitals and
the nurses on the frontlines the
hospital's repeatedly say we have what
we need or when they don't they come to
us we make sure they get it from the
stockpile or in new york city provides
from their stockpile then we hear
anecdotally from nice 'no pat cain the
nurses that the people on the frontlines
are operating under the crisis
conservation guidelines put out by the
cdc which is if you are running on a
shortage and you don't anticipate you're
necessarily gonna have additional coming
in you wear masks for days at a time you
wear gowns for a full shift instead of
changing between patients and so earlier
on that was something that was very real
because we had a shortage at this point
in the process we have been relieved of
that shortage and we've got what we
believe that we should have in the
hospital say that - so as we hear
anecdotal evidence from knives
nonspecific hospitals what we've now
done has gone to them and say we want
you to report to us are you operating
under the crisis conservation guidelines
are you operating under normal
guidelines and if it's the crisis
conservation guidelines why is it
because you don't have the proper supply
do you need us to help you backfill
where are you ordering from to solve
that because we want to make sure that
the nurses on the front line have what
they need to stay safe which doesn't
question governor the federal prison
Bureau is reporting which facilities
have how many coronavirus cases and the
deaths at those facilities do you think
the state prison system should do the
same I think it's a good idea I don't
know how practical it is but I think
it's a good idea there's a lot of
concern in some rural areas places like
Genesee County st. Lawrence County that
that they're beginning to see cases an
uptick in places like that what sort of
what sort of efforts are you guys going
to make to get out to those more remote
spots where testing might not not be as
widespread and where cases might rise
well I think you're going to see we
watch very carefully movement of the
virus we were watching movement towards
Long Island which has abated some what
we're watching movement towards nursing
homes if you look at the number of
deaths you'll see movement an increase
in nursing homes which in many ways was
inevitable because that's always where
the vulnerable population has been and
then they congregated obviously in one
facility so we watch the movement
geographically or demographically we
have not seen a significant uptick we
see little clusters pop up and then we
jump on the clusters when they pop up
additional testing resources etc when we
talk about that surge and flex you know
it works both ways
it was downstate we're now stabilized on
the imminent threat to the capacity of
the healthcare system so we have a
little breathing room in terms of
capacity and equipment and wherever we
see a pop up we jump on that immediately
I think you will see more
in less populated places the virus first
hits in the most dense locations right
why New York City it is one of the
densest places in the country just in
terms of concentration of people in a
small area of space right Los Angeles
but Los Angeles is like half the
population on like one and a half times
the geographic footprint it's the
density in New York City everybody going
into the transportation system walking
down a block in New York City you can't
do that the social distance is
practically impossible if everything was
open so that was the first wave if you
will I think you're gonna see that move
and there'll be more growth in more
suburban communities rural communities
especially in what they called these
super spreader situations which we
learned in New Rochelle New Rochelle
in Westchester the highest cluster why
it's in Westchester it's a suburban
community you don't have that density
that you have in urban areas one person
going to a gathering with 300 people
that's why the gatherings canceling st.
Patrick's Day which took a lot of grief
on was so right in retrospect one
gathering I mean a lot of people can get
infected and that can happen in any
suburban community in a rural community
so whenever we see it we will be there
we will be there
[Music]
Rockland and Orange counties and state
water New Jersey and why only New Jersey
[Music]
not that ambitious that's too many
pieces to coordinate for me that's too
many pieces of the puzzle it's not it's
not the it's when I talk tri-state area
the what we did on the closed-down was
the entirety of the state of New York
the entirety of the state of Connecticut
the entirety of the state of New Jersey
we are also going to work with
Pennsylvania Pennsylvania was very
involved in us with a marijuana regional
pact but obviously there's less
interaction on a day-to-day basis with
Pennsylvania than those other two states
so it will be a statewide plan for all
of New York all of New Jersey all of
Connecticut that is the optimum I'm not
promising that we're gonna try to get
all three states on the same page now
I'm sure if we do that not every local
government in Jersey not every local
government in Connecticut not every
local government in New York is going to
agree with every aspect of the plan by
the way they didn't all agree with every
aspect of the closed-down I mean I had a
lot of school districts unhappy with the
closed-down decision but you do the best
you can to come up with mutuality but at
one point you can't make everybody happy
with every decision
no they Brocklin than orange or in this
state so it's going to be the whole
state what that is the there is more
commutation from Westchester and Nassau
Suffolk just in terms of numbers but
Rockland aren't certainly but it'll be
the entire state it's not just Rockland
arms it's going to be upstate New York
mid-hudson this whole thing
yes but the closed-down plan was a
statewide plan it was every school
district in the state so every school
district had an opinion right many of
them were against that every county
executive had an opinion
maybe the county executives didn't agree
and I'm sure they're becoming executives
that I don't agree with this plan if
everybody agreed with it something would
probably be wrong happy Easter to
everybody is to do this from home happy